how's it hanging you racist
i'm dave rubin
i'm dave rubin it's february 3rd 2021.
this is the reuben report direct message
i should apologize that's not the right
way to start a show
you can't start a show by calling your
audience racist you're a bunch of racist
homophobic transphobic bigots
i'm sorry i tried to condense it into
one little thing how you doing people
good to be with you a lot of silliness
going on uh
some banana stories we're gonna have to
talk about from your
failing mainstream media and much more
uh quick reminder guys
people just keep telling me over and
over that you're being unsubscribed from
the channel you don't see the videos
click the bell click the other thing
there that says yeah i want to see the
videos and then when they unsubscribe
you click it again
i know it's a little cat and mouse game
that we're playing with the youtube
people but
please go ahead and do that okay i want
to get to the stories real quick today
because
uh they're just there's just like a lot
it's just like a lot we tried to
we tried to mix it up with the stories
today um so it's not all
purely political stuff it's some media
stuff and some educational stuff and
what not so first off uh there was a
clip going viral
yesterday from cnn now if you haven't
seen cnn it's it's a network that's on
uh airports although it won't be on much
longer they just
lost the contract and they're not going
to be on airports anymore which is
pretty great i was actually
flying out of dallas a couple days ago
and cnn was on and it's just interesting
because especially when it's muted which
in this case it was which was nice
nobody watches right and by the way it's
not like anyone would really watch
any airport tv we've all got phones and
uh most of them play both video and
audio and people just don't pay
attention to those things anyway cnn at
one time was a place of journalism they
had people
who did something in the proximity close
to actual journalism fact-finding
calling out both sides when they did
something wrong they were doing
something like that actually when i was
growing up i remember the first time
when i was really getting into politics
uh in around ninth grade i actually
started a little bit before probably
around seventh grade is when i was
sort of getting into politics but i
remember in ninth grade when the uh iraq
war started the first iraq war when
saddam hussein invaded kuwait
i remember our social studies teacher
having us watch cnn when we got home and
reporters on the ground and seeing
rockets
be fired and it was journalism it was
journalism well
it's not that anymore it's a place for
democratic activists to push
prop again and i've talked about this
before but if you don't think so i mean
just go through the list
of people that are on cnn are they
democrats or republicans like is it not
obvious and by the way
i don't care what they are if they would
just report honestly but like
these people i'll just name a couple
names do they strike you as democratic
activists or journalists jake tapper
at this point brian stelter jim acosta
chris cuomo wolf blitzer david axelrod
who i'm going to get to in a few minutes
don lemon these people are are all
democratic activists that that's just
what cnn is it just is
and you know i've been discussing over
the last couple weeks that one of the
things that
i think our challenge is going to be uh
as free thinking people who aren't
completely
locked into the matrix and and blue
pilled and just willing to swallow
whatever the media throws at us
is how much time should we spend talking
about the places that
promulgate the bad ideas like the
mainstream media right like
on one hand very few people are watching
them at this point on the other hand
they seemingly have influence because
they report on themselves and it feels
like they're still brainwashing a
certain amount of people which they are
and for those of us that don't buy into
it anymore on one hand it kind of feels
like oh we shouldn't
we should just ignore them and move on
and then on the other hand it's like you
want to keep calling out the nonsense so
you can wake up more people well this
clip that i'm about to show you is a
perfect
example of that so john king who again
i'm sure
is a democrat uh but that's sort of
irrelevant for this
he was doing a panel on this ridiculous
trump impeachment thing that nobody is
for nobody's for
except a couple far-left democrats and a
couple people in the media that just
want to keep you clicking on trump's
name nobody's for it the guy's gone
he's disappeared he's not on spotify
he's playing golf let him be okay
we've all moved on they can't move on
anyway they had a
legal analyst by the name of jennifer
rogers
on the show and i'm gonna play the clip
and spot if you can
find the lie uh council let me start
with you this is the 14 page brief filed
by the president's lawyers
uh it says number one this is
unconstitutional because he is a former
president
it says number two that he has a first
amendment right to speak
and therefore he said things at a rally
and people attack the capital
you can't hold him accountable yeah
those are wrong
and they're well countered by the very
long brief the house filed earlier today
i mean you don't have a first amendment
right to lie you don't have a first
amendment right
to put people in danger and he did both
of those things
and of course we know the jurisdictional
arguments were covered in about 40 pages
of the house's brief as well
that is extraordinary do you see what
just happened there
a cnn legal analyst by the name of
jennifer rogers i don't really care
about her
she just said that you don't have a
first amendment right to lie that trump
doesn't have a first amendment right to
lie which means that you don't have a
first amendment right to lie
think about what that means that means
that the government
can jail you or punish you otherwise if
you lie
we would all be in jail myself included
we've all lied we've all
had some white lies we've all lied about
bigger things i do my best
not to lie i try to tell you the truth
as much as possible and i try to do that
in my personal life as well but we all
lie and of course you're allowed to lie
under the first amendment what you can't
do under the first amendment
is a direct call for violence and then
we've got some very very
uh you know stringent laws around libel
and that sort of thing
but beyond that you're allowed to say
whatever you want you're actually
allowed to use hate speech because the
supreme court has decided it's not even
a thing
hate speech again you can't direct
people to violence you can't coordinate
a terror attack
that sort of thing but of course you
have the right to lie now she continued
on there for about 45 seconds
and then they went back to king and he
said nothing now anyone
can i get when you're interviewing
people sometimes they say kind of crazy
things and an interview can go on
believe me i know this
and you want to get to you want to get
back to something and then the whole
conversation has changed
i do long-form interviews so this
happens quite often someone will say
something but then they'll talk for
another two minutes
and then by the time i want to get back
to that original thing you know we've
moved on to something else and it feels
kind of crazy
to go all the way back there that's not
really how cable news operates though
because they do these very tight
quick sort of meaningless segments the
idea that
three other panelists there three other
people in those little cable news boxes
didn't come back and say uh you know i'm
not necessarily a legal analyst but
everyone with any level of education
knows that you actually are allowed to
lie
under uh the first amendment that it
does protect your right to lie
um could we just make a mention of that
thing
so you see what's going on here now many
people saw this and it went viral
and of course cnn as far as i know on
air has not issued any correction king
didn't do it then
and at no point throughout the day and
no no other i tweeted it
you know and then a lot of people saw it
and it's like of course stelter
mr reliable sources who keeps the media
you know in check he's the truth teller
it's like did he say anything about it
so then uh jennifer rogers did
once she realized how this clip was
going viral she did tweet at
directly at the dc examiner so that
means the only people that see this
tweet
are people who follow the dc examiner
and her that's a little insider trick of
twitter
she wrote this that was wrong obviously
people can lie
i meant to say trump has no first
amendment right to call
for a crime to be committed or to call
for something dangerous
sorry for the misstatement i mean no
like that's just not acceptable it's
completely not what you said
we know you can't call for violence we
we absolutely know that
you said you have no first amendment
right to lie
that person i just i don't believe that
in i'm not calling for a mob to come get
her or anything else
but that person should not be a legal
analyst that's on cnn anymore or i guess
it's
she's probably the perfect analyst to be
on cnn
but i would say there's something a
little more nefarious here which is that
in a way it's like that is kind of the
lie that cnn would want to push out to
their audience isn't it right
like wouldn't you want more people to
think that the government doesn't let
you lie
at the same time you're saying that so
many people in conservative media lie to
their audience
and give them misinformation and that
those people are subject to
disinformation and manipulation
and then if you started thinking well
wait a minute it's against the first
amendment for
those things to be said should we jail
these people should we
uh otherwise punish them so you can see
it's like sort of a lie that they would
kinda
kind of dig and and that's a that's a
pretty
pretty depressing statement um but you
know such is life
i then saw this tweet this morning from
david axelrod he's a senior
uh political analyst on cnn and you're
not going to believe this guys he was
also
a senior staffer in the obama
administration so i would imagine he'd
be completely impartial in everything
he's saying just because
you know george stephanopoulos who also
worked at the clinton
administration he runs abc news and we
know that basically everyone that's part
of any democratic administration
ends up on cnn or msnbc or abc or nbc or
the rest of it
but david axelrod had a tweet this
morning that i thought was sort of
interesting because i've been talking
about jen posaki a bunch on the show and
i think she's
basically completely incompetent despite
the fact she's getting only softball
questions she's of course
biden's press secretary axelrod wrote
jen pasaki is really putting on a clinic
on how the role of press secretary
should be done
smart direct and good humored honest
both about the information she shares
and about the questions she can't answer
immediately because she simply doesn't
know
boy are they holding power to account
over there at cnn
i mean do you think that that's real
analysis or is that a guy who works in
the democratic machine who then gets a
job at cnn
to then fluff basically the press
secretary for the president
who he likes right like he the president
now joe biden was the vp
under the guy that axelrod worked for
you think that that might have something
to do with it but this is all passed off
you've got lawyers literally lying to
you on cnn and then you've got cnn
analyst with just drivel
fluffing that's what it is it's fluffing
if you don't know what fluffing is
google it but not if you're at work
um that's what these people are
basically doing and i just think it's
important to know it but i am curious
your thoughts on this
if we should sort of still focus on this
nonsense
as their audience sort of crumbles or if
we should move ahead
you know i did a story what was it about
two weeks ago that they're very worried
at cnn
uh about youtubers that now have more
viewership than they do and our direct
messages this show
has absolutely been crushing it most of
our shows now are getting between two
and four hundred thousand
views again this is this is me and my
producer michael and my
director conor when we sit in here for a
few minutes and discuss what we're going
to talk about and then i go ahead and do
it
i have a thing in my ear here so i can
hear the clips but nobody's giving me
instructions
this is whatever comes out of my brain i
think it's a little more honest than
what's going on there but i really would
love to know your thoughts on this
what is it that we should do in this
strange time of disintegration should we
keep calling out
their nonsense because we want to make
sure more people know about it or is it
just
time to move forward um you can let us
know in the youtube comments down below
but
but the best place if you actually want
me to see it is reubenreport.locals.com
uh okay let's move on uh to a place
where things
actually seem like they're oh wait sorry
before we move on i do want to say one
other thing
i was on to just show you the difference
between say what cnn does
and scary fox news i want to just show
you something that happened to me in the
last couple days
before i get to this next story so on
friday when i was in dallas
i was on outnumbered on fox and for
those of you that haven't seen
outnumbered they have four
female co-hosts and uh
and then they have one male that comes
on i i was i was playing the mail on
that particular episode it's hosted by
harris faulkner and
uh there were a couple other kim klasik
who i've had on the show is on and tommy
lahren
and uh in the middle of the show about
15 minutes in it's an hour-long show
they cut to andrew cuomo's press
conference
about covid you'll see why i'm telling
you this story
related to the first story that we just
went through they cut to the
press conference and then we watched it
and they said hey we're going to show
this for about 10 minutes and then we'd
love for you guys to respond
so i watched it for about 10 minutes it
was absolutely embarrassing i mean cuomo
blames everybody but himself
he he actually blames god at one point
and several times he mentions that old
people are the ones dying and he
at least twice i think more references
his father mario cuomo who died
mario cuomo is the former governor of
new york i grew up in new york mario
cuomo my parents supported cuomo
he was a good governor much better than
his son but several times he mentioned
mario cuomo dying his elderly father
dying as he's talking about all of these
people dying of covid
so when we came back they threw to me
they asked me what i thought
i taught i told them how he's just you
know the buck stops with nobody's
kicking the can down the road
and that i'm sorry to hear that his
father mario cuomo died of
covid um but you know such is life
like okay you know he did he did not do
the good stuff
because the implication when he kept
bringing it up was that his dad died of
copay now it turns out
that his dad did not die of covet and i
think he intentionally conflated it
in the speech to make it sound like he
was the one
that was the victim here so you know
what happened just to show you the
difference between
fox news and cnn now i made a mistake
okay
absolutely i completely own up to it i
either misheard it or he intentionally
misled
whatever it is he's talking about old
people dying of cobit keeps bringing up
his father in his 80s
but i i botched it no doubt when we went
to commercial i got something in my ear
from the control room and they said dave
you know you actually
misspoke it turns out that his dad died
before kovid uh we'd like to issue a
retraction we'll have harris do it
harris is the main host
and i said i said well if i made a
mistake then absolutely you should do it
but i said i'm more than happy to do it
myself if i'm the one that made the
mistake harris doesn't have to
you know issue an apology on my behalf
they came back from commercial harris
threw to me
i said that uh that i butchered it and
that it turns out his dad died before
covet and that was it
anyway i think you see you see why i'm
telling you this whole story that in
that case
there was some misinformation that was
spoken
it was obvious they were going to issue
the retraction and i was more than happy
to do it myself
that is very different than what just
happened on cnn right there where they
everyone on that panel either knows that
you're allowed to lie under the first
amendment or is an
idiot it's one of the two and i didn't
see anyone on cnn
or even just the cnn communications team
why didn't the cnn communications team
throughout the day
just tweet out hey by the way our legal
analyst completely told you something
that was absolutely wrong today but
they just didn't do it anyway i just
thought juxtaposing those two situations
that happened within a couple days of
each other
and one of them happened to directly
involve me i thought that might be
interesting to you you're racist bigots
um all right next up
texas which is where i was last week and
it was open and it was wonderful and i
ate indoors with other human beings
and it was just incredible and we had a
great reuben report meet and greet which
was just wonderful seeing all you guys
uh well texas governor abbott uh is
calling for bolstering of civics
education
in the state pretty spectacular if i do
say so myself
but don't take my word for it let's
listen to governor abbott himself
this session we must
continue to fund education
as we promised
also if we expect the next generation of
texans
to keep texas the best state in the
nation
we must teach them why we are so
exceptional
we must educate them what it means to be
an american and what it means to be
a texan so we must bolster
civics education in our classrooms and
ensure that
eld learns the values of freedom
good governance and patriotism
good governance and good god i wish that
man was my governor
hashtag recall gavin newsom uh abbott is
saying a couple really interesting
things there he's saying if we are to
continue
if we are to continue then we got to do
something better
with education we need to start teaching
some patriotism we need to start
teaching
some civics you know all the time on
this show i'm always telling you guys
about
the three branches of government and
checks and balances and the difference
between the legislative branch and the
executive branch and the
judicial branch this is stuff that
really you're supposed to learn in
probably eighth ninth grade
that i don't think most people know and
most people seem to think the president
is allowed
to do whatever he wants and and as you
know that's basically how we're governed
at this point and it's and it's very
dangerous and it's completely counter
to why the united states was founded in
the first place that you wouldn't want
power
in the hands of the very few in this
case a king or a president
you would want it distributed throughout
the state and
allow people in a local sense to make as
much
decisions as many decisions for their
life as possible that's what you would
want that's the way it was set up it's
not really the way we do it
um but i love that he talks about
american and texan
there because he's saying that america
basically the country of america with
all the states
there is a national ethos here that we
should be proud of there
is something extraordinary that we have
done here in 250 years and
where are you allowed to talk about that
at this point who
out there do we have celebrities out
there that are talking about how great
america is do we have
uh newsmen or otherwise trusted sources
that are telling you how
great america is or pretty much
everywhere you go
in mainstream you're told how horrible
america is and that it was founded on
slavery not on the ideas of freedom and
all of this stuff
and texas has a pretty particularly
unique uh opportunity here because it is
now one of the places
that people are fleeing to right people
are fleeing
my god for sake and state of california
and they're going
to texas people are fleeing new york and
they're going to texas
well now if you're the average guy in
texas you better make sure that your
education system can stand up to social
justice can stand up to critical race
theory
otherwise you're going to turn blue
pretty damn quick and let's not forget
that beto o'rourke almost beat ted cruz
for senate that is d bet o'rourke who
his whole thing is anti-gun
almost beat ted cruz in the great state
of texas
so the idea that we would teach more
civics
more pride in america that you're
allowed to be patriotic i don't want
propaganda
taught i want an honest assessment of
the country
and by the way we do a really good job
of that
almost everywhere you know i've
mentioned this a few times i've been to
thomas jefferson's estate at monticello
in virginia i've been there many times
and when you take the tour they
mostly talk about slavery now there's an
awful lot that they could talk about
with thomas jefferson but they do not
only do they acknowledge slavery i would
say a disproportionate amount of the
tour is focused on slavery this guy did
an awful lot of stuff
when you go to george washington's house
right outside of dc
and you take the tour which i did about
a year ago a little over a year ago
they focus a tremendous amount of
slavery it's not that we're ignoring our
past
we're not ignoring our past um but we
have to also acknowledge that a lot of
good stuff happened too
and i hope we'll get better at that you
know and this is the great question for
those of you that that believe anything
that i've said here
are there any state education
systems that actually work anymore i
don't know that there are
you know we're working on having kids
and it's like am i would i ever
send my kids to a california state
school you know what i mean like a a an
elementary school
that was that was state focused where
they're gonna get all of this bad
information
and by the way then what do the
democrats want to do at the same time
they want to stop charter schools and
they want to stop school choice because
as i always say if you want to
indoctrinate people what would be the
best place to do it other than a
california
state school so anyway i just think this
is super interesting and i hope that
i hope the texas and abbott are able to
get this stuff into the curriculum and
maybe that will spread to some of the
other states
uh but let's jump as our final story to
our
friends up north the canadians
uh because they've got their own set of
problems there and this has been coming
for a long time
uh and you remember that jordan peterson
guy who by the way
has a new book coming out next month and
yes he will
be on the show he has been slowly coming
back we've talked a little bit on the dl
yesterday he he tweeted at me about
coming back on to get a little
a little public excitement going so yeah
the band is getting back together
and jordan will be on the show in about
a month to launch his new book and i
hope we get to talk obviously a little
bit about
uh you know what he's been through for
these last two years which was
uh in his words it was a pretty brutal
experience um but
but he's getting there he's not 100 but
he's getting there but i hope we get to
talk about that and i hope
we get to talk about the year that we
spent together which was which was
pretty magical you know
in 2018 most of 2018 into summer 2019
you know basically
um traveling the world and and helping
people help themselves it was it was
extraordinary it was a life-changing
moment in many ways it feels like a
dream to me
when i think back on it i'm like wow
that was incredible we did 120 stops in
20 countries
talking to all these people it was it
was awesome and i hope to do something
like that one day again and maybe when
i don't think jordan will be touring
this book obviously because of covet and
his health stuff but
maybe when my next book comes out which
i'm working on right now
maybe we'll get to do that sort of thing
anyway
jordan has been warning about all of the
stuff around
hate speech and online hate in canada
for a long time as you remember one of
the things that put him on the map
in a in a worldwide sense was that he
was fighting against
the incoming legislation that would
allow the government to punish you if
you misgendered someone
his point was not to be mean to trans
people or treat trans people differently
or anything like that his point was that
the government doesn't have the right
to compel speech he as he said many
times and as i have said many times and
any one sensible has said many times of
course you want to treat trans people
with respect
and they should be treated equally under
the law and all of those things but if
you
either intentionally or accidentally
misgender someone walking down the
street
should you be fined or put in jail
that's what he was fighting against and
canada now
they don't have the first amendment
protections that we have
uh jennifer rogers on cnn is a little
confused as to what those first
amendment protections are
but the protections that we have
basically allow you to say
whatever you want without direct threats
there's a couple other things the fire
in a crowded theater with the intent to
do harm okay we all know all this stuff
at least i think most of us know this
stuff we have to do better in terms of
civics
but that's a previous story um anyway
the canadian government is saying that
quote online hate legislation is coming
soon
this is from the supreme court of canada
i mean this is just extraordinary
i agree with the arguments that the
quest for truth is an essential
component of the marketplace of ideas
which
is itself central to a strong democracy
the search for truth is also an
important part of self-fulfillment
now here's a line you got to really
focus in on this is from the supreme
court of canada
however i do not think it is
inconsistent with these views to find
that not all
truthful statements must be free from
restriction
not all truthful statements must be free
from restriction
truthful statements that can be
interlaced with harmful ones or
otherwise presented in a manner that
would meet the definition
of hate speech i mean that is
absolutely extraordinary absolutely
extraordinary this is coming from the
supreme
court of canada and let me just say
something about our first amendment
which again will confuse jennifer rogers
at cnn
the world is jealous
jealous of our first amendment that you
can say whatever you want
and it is on the ropes right now it is
very very obvious whether it's through
lying
talking heads on cnn or people like aoc
who want
commissions to study misinformation ah
that would be interesting so the
government
will fund things to potentially close
down media outlets wouldn't that
actually be an infringement on the first
amendment why why yes
it would um people worldwide are jealous
of our freedoms and now i think you
understand why let me read that line one
more time
however i do not think it is
inconsistent with these views
to find that not all truthful statements
must be free from restriction
what what truthful statement would you
want restricted
uh i believe it was jim carrey who said
the truth will set you free
and liar a liar he's definitely the one
that came up with that right um
yeah of course you should be allowed to
speak the truth if we don't have the
truth we don't have anything
like truth or bust people that's it so
the idea that they're coming in here and
saying oh you might say something true
but that could also be laced
with some mean things or hate speech
hate speech there's no such thing
according to the united states supreme
court
on hate speech it does not exist you're
allowed to say
mean things to people you're allowed to
say mean things
about groups you can't instigate
violence against them
and i would prefer that people be nice
and not bigoted and not racist but you
just
are allowed to speak freely at least
here in america and at least for now
canada has a whole other situation
brewing right now and these are
important things to think about because
what is happening across the west across
the western societies
we are seeing expansions of government
that are infringing on people's ability
to communicate
and that is that is not good how about
that
for ana for analysis it is not good
people
all right guys uh this friday uh i'm
doing a panel
on faith and belief and non-belief
in these crazy times i'm going to be
with eric mataxis
who's been on the show before who's
fantastic david wolpe rabbi david welby
who's also been on the show and my
friend peter bogosian who is a
non-believer so we've got a christian
a jew and a non-believer and we're going
to talk about
belief and purpose and meaning in these
sort of crazy
political times i know you guys have
been enjoying the panel shows and i
think this one will be particularly
meaningful uh by the way part two with
my interview
uh part two of my interview with andy
noe who is
like been the guy on the front lines of
everything going on with antifa
for for years now and it's been a true
joy to watch this guy
grow i feel like i knew him when he was
a kid and he's just like
grown and grown and grown and grown and
he's a true journalist and i can say it
without doing
the air quote thing he's a true
journalist part two is up on youtube
right now the full episode is up totally
ad free at rubinreport.locals.com
speaking of locals i got a whole bunch
of meetings today i'm basically i've i
gave myself another job in the midst of
all this if i wasn't busy enough so i
got i got some other stuff
to get to so have a great day everybody
and we'll see you tomorrow